Westwood: Hi. My name
is Dave Westwood.
I'm the co-founder
of BuddyPoke!
And the engineer
of a team of two.
Uh, Randall Ho, my friend,
is the other member of the team,
and he works on the content,
and the content pipeline,
and the avatar creation.
Uh, we're currently known
for one application
called BuddyPoke!
It's a 3-D avatar
poking app, uh,
that's on many, uh,
OpenSocial networking sites.
We first released, uh,
BuddyPoke! on--on MySpace
in early April.
And App Engine
came out, um, in mid-April,
and we immediately
jumped on it.
Um, it's been a godsend
in--in terms of, uh,
scalability over the last
several months.
Um, it only took about a week
to port App Engine.
And that was porting
to Orkut.
So let me show you a demo
of, uh, BuddyPoke!
running on Orkut.
Okay, so this is BuddyPoke!
running inside Orkut.
When a user first adds
the application,
they're gonna see
something like this.
It's a very kind of vanilla
avatar.
We have the tools over
on the right-hand side here
to personalize your avatar.
You can go through
and you can--
you can customize
your hair.
Give yourself
some hair streaks.
That kind of thing.
For now, let's just pick
a preset.
You could basically create
a kitty, or an army man,
or maybe a little
goth girl.
So let's save her.
And we're now looking
at some of the BuddyPoke!,
um, actions
that users
have already done.
So here's--I'll just go
through some previous events.
And you get a general
feeling for what you can do.
It's all about creating
an avatar.
You now have a personal
connection with this avatar.
It's either representing
yourself,
or it's representing,
you know,
some character
that you like.
Might be a fantasy character
or a famous star.
And then you can basically
poke a friend.
So we have glump, hug,
kissing.
We have soccer
for our Brazilian fans.
Guitars.
That kind of thing.
So let's save a poke.
And for those people
that initially add the app,
they don't typically have
many friends.
So we have, uh,
we have mood changes too.
And we can just be
meditating.
So it's actually a very simple
application to use.
There's pretty much
three, um, things you can do.
Customize your avatar,
change your mood,
and poke a friend.
And we're working on this--
images over on the side here.
So let me explain to you
how that actually works
in terms of utilizing
App Engine on the server side.
If you look at this graph,
you can actually see
we've had a very fast growth
on Orkut.
Orkut went live to Brazil,
and shortly thereafter
we saw pretty much an 8x
jump in installs overnight,
which sort of blew us away
in terms of, you know,
the--the expected growth
that we thought we would have.
And that's all thanks to,
you know, App Engine's ability
to scale.
Um, so if you think back
to the demo,
we basically have--it's--
it's a very simple application.
You can save an avatar,
you can poke a friend,
and you can change
your mood.
Um, each one of those
is a-a call to App Engine.
And that stores, um, a db_model
into the datastore.
Um, and we actually store
just Jason, um, chunks
as db_text.
Um, when we first went live
with this on App Engine,
uh, we sort of
didn't fully understand, um,
the architecture
of, uh, BigTable
and how--
how Google App Engine scales.
Um, I went to Google I/O,
and I went to Brad
and Ryan's talks,
and many others,
and basically learned
how App Engine
is architectured.
And I highly recommend watching
the Google I/O, uh, videos
that are available
on YouTube.
Um, it--you know, I started off
doing things
like db queries,
which are a lot slower
than doing things like, uh,
db_model, uh, get value
by key name.
Um, and just doing things,
like, I was including dates
in my database model when
I wasn't actually using them.
And it's, like, well,
if I'm not using them,
why include them at all?
Um, so there's a lot
of things that you can do
to improve the performance
of your applications.
And then obviously
you can let App Engine
just take care of the rest
by doing the scaling.
Um, another good thing
to know about
is doing things
like sharded counters.
Um, I ran into this thing
where I was just use--
using a counter to--
to count my installs.
Um, and it's--you can see
in the graph, um,
obviously, when you get
so many installs,
you--you have to start using
sharded counters
to make sure you can handle,
um, the number of hits
to your datastore.
Otherwise you're gonna run
into concurrency problems.
So you've seen BuddyPoke!
Um, I've showed you
how it--how it's scaled
to approximately
13 million users.
Uh, we're currently live
on four different sites.
And hopefully soon
we'll be live
on four or five
other different sites.
And hopefully we'll be up to--
to 20 million users
very soon.